yeah pay my mama's rent now and that's
gotta feel awesome it's nice to know she
don't have to worry she works hard she's
like 77 or something and she's still
like you know deliver stuff and um yeah
it is nice to know that she can take the
day off for something she wants to and
you have to [ __ ] think about paying
something that's gotta be it's pretty
much that's god that's like gotta feel
outstanding yeah it's not really like
about it yeah what how's the
relationship talk about it
I never I've always had a tough time
hearing my mother you know I felt like I
don't know I just have always had a
little like uh I think you know
sometimes I think the reason I do
comedies because I wanted my mom to
laugh or something I was young and I
couldn't get her to laugh yeah and so I
it like spun out into this weird thing
where that's what I was doing you know
because I remember my dad laughing all
the time but I never met I've added you
yeah generally yeah just laughing just
having a good time
oh good having a good to have him you
having a good time yeah and then I don't
remember my mother having that at all
and I think there was always like this
stress that she was stressed and I
couldn't do anything
you know just yeah I think that's the
the the
I've seen study a lot of comedians is
about making your mom laughs yeah that's
a big one as much as it's like weird sad
clowns and all that stuff it's a lot of
it's sad
children children of sad moms yeah why
honestly a lot of times that's the
formula for comedians that should be a
club yeah
children would sama my mom's not sad my
mom is uh I always felt like there's
like Plexiglas between us mmm
like ah like I want a [ __ ] more of a
connection and we just can't get there
yeah like we just can't it just doesn't
that's not she doesn't know how to do it
yeah she's a good mom yeah it was like
did the you know like like attentive and
all that stuff just emotionally and
that's that that's another generational
thing where my mom's 85 so yeah like
I don't she doesn't know them like
emotion the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah yeah we can't really think about
that kind of more than 19 she born
during the Great Depression yeah
1933 like I don't forget imagine she was
three Wow like she got split up but one
of her sisters went to Ireland and then
they couldn't pick her up because of the
war yeah yeah what we're not coming this
week yeah does you have a Hitler can you
imagine that though all the time
especially on saw mr. ug see all these
families just got split up we were kids
we couldn't afford it the orphanages -
yeah it's like like my mom's mom died
and then she had two sisters maybe three
and each uncle took a different one or
each aunt took a different one but
meanwhile the dad was still alive they
just were like yeah yeah we're not leave
not gonna dad that's insane yeah this is
the hill they'll be dead in a week and
even with a guy so they went to the
aunts and then the dad was like I'm
getting ready and I was like mom how
long did he need to get ready for and it
he never really got it together Wow
yeah and then he remarried like his mate
just crazy [ __ ] 30s and 40s it but so
and then I'm like where's the feeling
but why is there blessing because the
[ __ ] Hitler and the Great Depression
that's why you [ __ ] shy yeah that's a
Boyle brat that's what I realized a lot
of times to men and I think about that
too about myself man I'm just a [ __ ]
brat like yeah at some point it's like
[ __ ] I also have to realize look dude
you have to just [ __ ] take care of
yourself you have to find a way to do it
you can't think at a certain point you
can't think about all this [ __ ] too much
it's a / - life's a plan of a program of
action you got to take action and get
yourself feeling good you got to get
yourself doing something you have to
just get going you know yeah it's crazy
to think sometimes that yeah our parents
who probably had no whose parents to
them probably didn't teach them much
about emotions or anything at all the
Rockefellers
had emotions brah they were [ __ ] all
out of their minds - yeah they'd like
the Rockefellers doing like no the
Rockefellers pair John Rocker Bella's
dad was probably a [ __ ] coal miner
yeah there wasn't well you know I mean
like they there wasn't like crazy like
three people were rich yeah everybody
else [ __ ] lived in Appalachia yeah I
mean not literally but like there was no
like there was a robust middle-class no
life was [ __ ] brutal e-everyone [ __ ]
in an outhouse like even if you were
there there's this book called sapiens
it's really good but they were so the
guy was saying like there were French
French like the king of we live better
than the King of France from 1700 Wow
Wow
King of France 79 shat out side damn no
in didn't have he had somebody to carry
it out there for Mom yeah no Pete had
held hands going by him by himself but
like he didn't have a [ __ ] there was
no indoor heat no indoor air game there
was no he no car no like nothing so no
ice no ice Theo so so we have it good
but at the same time it's not perfect
yeah
damn yeah you'd have somebody whose
bodies numbers was a little lower just
blow on you all that yeah yeah bring in
the cool in here and he would blow on it
yeah like we don't we it's hard
put problems or problems problems or l
know as much as you are like as much as
its if they were alive today they'd have
the same problems we have yeah which is
I don't feel quite right I don't feel I
feel isolated feel alienated I feel
emotionally I feel whatever all the
things that we deal with that's our
version of shooting outside yeah yeah
it's our version of sitting outside in
the private but that but then the the
part that we can't control is how do we
what do we do about it yeah taking
action or not taking action yeah and I
think yeah for me this show just got
caught in a place where I was in
everything else was too much and I
wasn't able to focus on that at all and
so now I'm like a
get back to focusing on it it's
definitely getting more man but evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better what if
you watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one